i used to break horses  with our son james  [Music]  what was compelling to me in painting a  portrait of  this marriage between george and  margaret  was that as scary and violent as the  movie is  there is this real authentic connection  between them he isn't far  just in town when i read the script i  thought wow these are really rich  parts easy to hear they're written so  beautifully  that it's hard to take your eyes off  these characters  happy happy not to hear a lecture  it kind of regress into their  weakest version of themselves  what the hell margaret they're going  through the most tragic thing  a married couple ever experienced the  loss of a son  and they both deal with it in such a  different way  when you finally learned that what you  want to make happen isn't going to  happen  what then margaret my way cuts  [Music]  you